on passe à un tout autre sujet on parle
à parler transport le nombre de
véhicules électriques et hybrides de
rechargeables à tripler en 5 ans et cela
pourrait s'intensifier dans les années à
venir notamment avec la fin de la vente
de véhicule thermique 9 en 2035 mais
aussi face à l'explosion des prix du
carburant à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'agglomération a décidé de déployer des
bornes publiques de recharge pour
véhicules électriques et pour en parler
avec nous Grégory canalet journaliste de
la rédaction ces bornes de recharge pour
voiture électrique ont été lancées
officiellement ce matin à Élancourt et
elles sont baptisées Starsky oui Starsky
ça fait tout de suite penser à ça
[Musique]
le générique de cette série TV alors qui
parle je pense à tout le monde peut-être
tout le monde n'a pas vu Starsky et
Hutch mais je pense que le générique est
connu une série des années 70 Starsky et
Hutch qui suit les aventures de deux
policiers et de basity une ville
imaginaire en Californie David
start-geki et kennetou et pour qu'au 50
ans en Yvelines l'agglomération c'est
directement inspiré de la série pour le
nom de son dispositif et pour la
communication tout autour on a vu il y a
même la voiture qui s'inspire de la
série Starsky et Hutch alors c'est un
réseau de bande de recharge électrique
Starski pour véhiculer électrique les
voitures les motos mais aussi les vélos
ils s'appuie sur près de 30 points de
charge déjà présent à Maurepas
Coignières plaisir Villepreux et donc
depuis peu à Élancourt sur la place de
l'Hôtel de Ville cette dernière borne
est multimodale ça veut dire qu'on peut
y recharger deux véhicules à la fois
d'autres vont être installés dans les
prochains mois l'objectif pour
l'agglomération c'est de déployer
de bornes à la mi 2023 pour arriver
petit à petit à plus de 100 bornes
présentes sur le territoire opérationnel
et ce dans les 12 communes de
l'agglomération on a déjà avec les 28
bandes que nous avons on a pu regarder
collecter quelques datas donc c'est pas
des Data personnel mais les Data
d'utilisation qui nous permettent de
voir où il serait pertinent d'avoir des
bancs là où ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
moins on a aussi une un objectif de
service public donc principalement ce
sera basé dans le centre-ville parce
qu'on aussi besoin de faire fonctionner
le commerce donc et l'idée c'était
d'avoir aujourd'hui alors que c'était
que sur cinq villes d'étendre minimum
deux bandes de recharge dans les 12
villes du territoire c'est toujours vu
en relation en coopération effectivement
avec les mairies mais également les
habitants donc voilà c'est intéressant
qu'ils habitent en puissent se mobiliser
remonter les informations auprès des
mairies et alors comment ça fonctionne
concrètement Grégory la localisation de
La Borne elle peut se faire via les
applications mobiles de mobilité de
conduite et d'électromobilité
fraîchemile
trop Maps ou Milo voici quelques
exemples ou directement sur le site de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une carte
interactive vous permet de localiser
très rapidement la borne et d'en
connaître les caractéristiques une fois
sur place le déverrouillage de la borne
le paiement également se fait avec un
badge d'un opérateur de mobilité
compatible ou directement grâce à votre
carte bleue sans contact il est la
possibilité de brancher tout type de
prise en acier ou en décès et la
question qui nous intéresse le plus
Grégory combien ça coûte alors plusieurs
tarifs selon la puissance de charge
celle qui est déjà proposée par
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est l'offre standard jusqu'à 22
kilowattheure votre véhicule se recharge
en 2h30 3h le coût 30 centimes d'euro le
kilowattheure dans la limite de 3 heures
attention au delà de 3 heures de
recharge une surfacturation s'applique
de 25 centimes par minute l'idée
d'assurer un certain roulement entre les
véhicules que ce ne soit pas juste des
places de stationnement mais bien des
places de recharge pour votre véhicule
électrique est très prochainement de
nouvelles possibilité dans
l'agglomération l'offre Express qui ira
jusqu'à 50 kilowattheure qui sera
déployée dans un second temps c'est à
dire une recharge entre une heure et
1h30 60 centimes d'euros par
kilowattheure 60 centimes de rouge je
répète par kilowattheure j'ai un petit
peu écorché dans la limite d'une heure
trente maximum et au-delà de cette
limite il y en a même surfacturation qui
s'applique de 25 centimes par minute et
puis l'offre boost elle qui sera
déployée dans une troisième phase
jusqu'à 150 kWh et là c'est Express
Mathilde c'est très rapide le véhicule
se remplit la batterie se remplit en 30
45 minutes les tarifs sont les mêmes que
pour l'offre Express un 60 centimes
d'euros par kilowattheure avec une
surfacturation qui s'applique à partir
d'une heure trente d'utilisation alors
je crois que vous avez un bon plan
Grégory c'est de plutôt recharger la
nuit entre 22h et 8 heures du matin les
tarifs sont réduits de 30% ce qui donne
du 20 centimes le kilowattheure pour
l'offre standard 40 centimes pour les
offres boost et Express autre avantage
pas surfacturation appliquée dans cette
tranche horaire merci beaucoup Grégory
canalet pour toutes ces précisions